>> Maria Russo: Hi
everyone, welcome.
I am Maria Russo, I'm the
children's books editor
at the New York Times
Book Review.
And I am so happy
to welcome here
to the National Book
Festival and we're grateful
to the Library of Congress
for making it possible
Marisha Pessl.
>> Marisha Pessl: Hello.
[ Applause ]
>> Maria Russo: Who.
>> Marisha Pessl:
Thank you so much.
>> Maria Russo: It's so
great to have you here
and you're here on the YA stage.
>> Marisha Pessl: Yes.
>> Maria Russo: Which is
a new place for Marisha.
As you guys probably
know Marisha
as an adult fiction writer,
her new book Neverworld Wake
is her first foray into YA.
And the big question people
always have about any YA writer,
but especially one who came
like you from the world
of adult fiction where
your books, Special Topics
in Calamity Physics and
the second one Night Film,
I have always wanted to say
Night Train, Night Film were
so well received and
considered you know
such incredible works
of fiction.
Why would an author decide
to write for teenagers
and decide to write YA?
That is my first
question for you.
>> Marisha Pessl: Oh thank
you so much and thank you
for being here and
to all of you.
It's actually something that
I, I always knew that I wanted
to write for children
even before I published my
first novel.
Books were such an important
part of me as a young person.
First and foremost, I'm a
reader even before I'm a writer.
So I always knew that I wanted
to contribute to that space
at some point, I didn't
know how or when I just knew
at some point an idea
would strike me that seemed
at home more in the YA space
than in the adult space.
So about two years ago
or so I was working
on my third adult novel
when I had the idea
of this very claustrophobic
tightknit group
of former high school
students stuck not only
in a remote location
but also stuck in time.
And there was just something
about the nature of this story
that felt that it needed to
be YA, simply because the age
of the teenagers I wanted
them just a little bit removed
from that, you know, the
pressure cooker of high school.
So I really set out to write
this book as a side project
and was very excited
to enter this space.
>> Maria Russo: And
really it grew and became,
we should talk a little bit
about the plot of the novel.
Just if anyone here has
had a chance to read it yet
and if not, we're
hoping you'll pick it up
and Marisha will do
some signing, right?
>> Marisha Pessl:
Yes, I'll be signing.
>> Maria Russo: So as Marisha
said, it's set the year
after the main characters have
graduated from high school.
They are going back to the house
where they spent a
lot of time together.
>> Marisha Pessl: Yes.
>> Maria Russo: When
they were in high school.
And can you give us your
elevator pitch of what happens
when they all five of them.
>> Marisha Pessl: Yes,
so one year after they've
graduated high school they all
return for a reunion of sorts
to a remote estate
belonging to one of them.
And they were all very tightknit
in high school but the death
of the sixth member of
their group really tore them
all apart.
So our main character
Beatrice returns hoping,
a year later hoping
to get some questions.
And as all big moments in one's
mind the reality never matches
with what you've hoped.
So after a series of
short conversations
where she's really not
getting to the bottom
of you know what exactly
happened to the sixth member
of their group they have
a near-death collision
and they survive
and return home.
And that is when a stranger
knocks on the door and announces
that they've entered
the neverworld wake.
And you really have to read the
book to find out what this is.
But it is a break in
the space-time continuum
where they relive the same
hours over and over again.
And that is really how the novel
unfolds, they have to figure
out how to free themselves.
>> Maria Russo: Really
what was so cool to me
about this book is how
it reads like realism,
like you really believe
these people exist.
And yeah, as you can see it's
actually a work of high fantasy,
it's a time travel,
time-space continuum plot.
So how did you balance
those two, those two genres?
How do make it seem so
realistic when they're jumping
around in time, they're
living the same day
over and over again?
There's all kinds of.
>> Marisha Pessl: Yeah, so I
always put my, I mean I think
with all novels you know
even when there is an element
of fantasy I want it to
be grounded in reality
as if this is actually
happening.
So it's really just a
question of putting yourself
in that circumstance and
figuring out how it's going
to unfold as if you
were actually there.
And the idea started
from the standpoint
of an unsolved mystery and
I was struck by the idea
that some mysteries
are unsolved simply
because of the parameters
of a human life.
And that we can't
possibly synthesize all,
an amount of information
in a given lifespan.
And we also only have 24
hours a day to work with.
So I was thinking what if that
change and someone had infinity
or at least the perception of
infinity to solve this mystery.
So it really came from there.
And of course there's an element
of Groundhog Day which was one
of my favorite movies.
And Groundhog Day is such an
endemic part of our culture,
it's just like another
kind of conceit to use.
So I was thinking like you
know getting beyond that.
So the characters
are reliving it
and they have their different
experiences of what that means.
But I always wanted
a push and see
from a psychological standpoint
what's beyond simply being
trapped in time, like you know
how that is going to unfold.
>> Maria Russo: You know now
that you mention it it's
reality, it's science fiction,
but it also is mystery
you're right.
>> Marisha Pessl: Right.
>> Maria Russo: Because
when they go back
and relive each day
they're trying
out different theories
about this murder.
They're trying to
get more information.
>> Marisha Pessl: Yes.
>> Maria Russo: An increasingly
outrageous, there's just a lot
of because at a certain point
they realize the stakes are
so low if they shoot someone,
if they shoot themselves.
The next day they wake up
and everything's the same.
>> Marisha Pessl: Right.
>> Maria Russo: So the
plot gets really kind
of totally wild by the end.
>> Marisha Pessl: Right, right.
>> Maria Russo: But I mean,
but you are following the
rules of a murder mystery.
>> Marisha Pessl: Yes, I mean I
think I have such a love affair
with the murder mystery
as an idea
because I think it's my trojan
horse to explore other elements
of what it means to be human.
You can go really deep within
the conceit of a murder mystery.
And I'm a big Agatha Christie
fan, she was actually one
of my favorite authors
and still is in some ways.
So I love to keep the audience
guessing and have that sort
of clockwork puzzle, but
you can within that explore
so many phenomenal themes
with that narrative pull
pulling the reader along.
>> Maria Russo: Right, right.
And the other theme that really
jumps out besides the sort
of life, death, limits
of a life,
limits of a day is this
theme of friendship
between these characters and how
you think you know your friend
so well.
And this is of course taking
place at a boarding school,
so they really thought
they knew each other,
they lived with each
other for many years.
And then it turns out
none of them knew any
of the others really
at enough, at all.
>> Marisha Pessl: Yes, I mean
I think the longer I've been a
writer I'm just fascinated,
well actually when I was
on book tour someone
asked me like what I love
and what I'm afraid of.
And it's a human being because
human beings are capable
from such a range of acts,
benevolent and truly evil.
So there's such a
range within that.
And the more as a novelist you
work on character and you work
on human psychology you
realize you can never really get
to the end of a human
being in terms
of the core of who someone in.
Personality is so much
influenced by time,
circumstance, mood, whether or
not someone's had a large lunch,
so I mean it kind
of all depends.
So within this timeframe
of infinite time what does
it means to, like continue
to get to know somebody.
And I mean human beings are
infinite well that's kind
of what I figured out as well.
>> Maria Russo: Right,
right, it does seem that way.
The main character Beatrice
especially is an interesting
study in this because she's
for most of the book we sort
of take her word
and sort of assume
that she's the good girl
right, she's the simple one
that they all not
necessarily look down on
but they all consider her oh
boring, [inaudible] Beatrice.
>> Marisha Pessl: Yes.
>> Maria Russo: And then in
fact we learn at the end.
>> Marisha Pessl: Yes.
>> Maria Russo: Two fairly major
secrets which we won't spoil.
>> Marisha Pessl:
Yes, no spoilers.
But yeah, so I mean I think
especially in high school it's
so easy to really pigeonhole
people as you were trying
to make your own way
as a young person.
And even thinking back in my
own life you know thinking back
to all the different characters
or people that I knew I sort
of made certain assumptions
about them.
And then later as
an adult I found
out really what the reality was
of what was going in a friend
of mine's house or what
you know they were dealing
with in their family situation.
So you just really realize
as a young person there's
such a huge universe that
is out of sight and not
within your daily experience.
Abd so I wanted to explore that
and I think the messages is
really, not that anything boils
down to a message in the
book, but it's about empathy
and understanding that there's
so much of personal history
that one does not now.
So it allows you to.
>> Maria Russo: It's really
important for high school.
>> Marisha Pessl:
To approach people
with a little bit more
I would say grace.
>> Maria Russo: Further
possibilities that each person.
>> Marisha Pessl: Yes.
>> Maria Russo: Holds.
And another theme that
as if there wasn't enough
in this book already, another
them I really like that sort
of snuck up on me at the and
was a kind of feminist approach
to you know men take women's
words and women's work
and take credit for it a lot.
And as a woman you have to be
really careful, are you helping
by giving your work away to men
who get the credit and the glory
or are you destroying
kind of both of you.
>> Marisha Pessl: Yes, I mean
I think, I'm so glad you picked
up on that because I've actually
never talked about that before.
But yes, I think I was
inspired by the fact
that throughout history women
through their love
have supported so much
and allowed others really
to stand on their shoulders.
So there are certainly elements.
>> Maria Russo: You
have the male genius.
>> Marisha Pessl: Yes.
>> Maria Russo: Like we start
the book thinking there are
these two male characters who
are just kings of the world
and it's not quite, all is
not as it seems with them.
>> Marisha Pessl: Yes.
>> Maria Russo: Either.
>> Marisha Pessl:
Right, right exactly.
>> Maria Russo: So there's
that, really that was one
of those threads that you
just kind of wove in there
and then hold at the very end.
>> Marisha Pessl: Right.
Well some of it it's
interesting,
some of it is plot ahead of time
and then some of these elements
of character that you're
mentioning, some of it just sort
of seeps in kind
of inadvertently.
And so those are those things
that you can't necessarily plan.
>> Maria Russo: That's true.
Well since you mentioned that
people are always curious
about a novelist's process.
>> Marisha Pessl: Yes.
>> Maria Russo: Could you
describe what your typical,
you know, the journey
of the manuscript is.
>> Marisha Pessl:
Yes, in a nutshell.
So I always start out with
some sort of gut idea.
And it's interesting sometimes
I'll think I have an idea
for a novel, but then it
will wither really quickly
over like three days when I'm
starting to think about it
and I'm like oh it's not big
enough, it's not strange enough,
it's not wild enough,
it's not different enough.
So you know I'll put
an idea like that aside
or I'll just write it down and
put it in a drawer somewhere.
But so you start with the
idea and I really do a lot
of research ahead of time in
a novel with pen and paper
and writing out characters
and writing out plot points
that seem unusual that I
haven't seen before in a book
or something that would
be really thrilling.
So just doing a lot of that
character work and plotting
with pen and paper,
like writing longhand.
And then I'll start to
develop really a buyable
for the writing, before
I've really written
on the [inaudible] yet.
>> Maria Russo: Oh like
a TV show [inaudible]?
>> Marisha Pessl: Yeah,
like a TV show [inaudible].
And with character, plot points,
a few visuals, definitely not
like visuals of the characters
but things that allow me
to get a sense of the texture
of the character, like the logo
on their sweatshirt or what
kind of shoes they would wear
or you know something that they
would cut out of a magazine
or something like that.
So I kind of have a
sense of each character.
And then at that point after
maybe I would say that's
about a month's time, then
I'll start the writing.
And the writing is really
just like an excavation,
like you just have
to keep going deeper.
And I was giving
writing advice recently
to someone who's writing
their first novel and they're
like worried about
their opening paragraph.
And I'm like that opening
paragraph is actually going
to be the final thing that
you write, so don't even worry
about what your first
sentence is.
It's like you know dive in
and you're just like you have
to keep just digging
and digging and digging.
And then when you think you're
finished, then you bring
in your editor and then
you'll realize you've really
just started.
There's always a moment
where I think I'm finished
and the editor comes back to
me and I'm like oh my gosh.
It's really funny, there's
so of writing that's complete
psychological like mind bending,
you think something is good
and then you come back
later and you realize whoa.
So it's really just about
coming back again and again,
working with your editor,
and you know allowing
something to kind of solidify.
>> Maria Russo: Was this book
easier than the first two,
does it get easier
the third time?
>> Marisha Pessl:
I don't think so.
I mean I think for me I really
like to challenge myself.
If I think that something's easy
then I really think I'm way off.
So no, I think there is
was a speed to the writing
because I did plot a
lot of it out beforehand
so I was writing much faster
than I wrote Special
Topics or Night Film.
But I also went back
and probably wrote the
book two more times.
>> Maria Russo: Wow and was
there anything especially
helpful that your
editor said or did?
>> Marisha Pessl: Oh
yes, I mean I had,
I was telling you before I had
a wonderful young adult editor,
she's obviously different
than my adult editor.
And she was great, I mean
she's, I wouldn't even say
that she's a young adult editor
she's just a great editor.
So she was pushing me really
on, she really pushed me
on the emotional aspect
of things and I love
that because sometimes
I can get very
into like the cerebral
puzzle part of it.
And she's the one who pushed me
with like the heart,
the heart, the hear.
It's harder for me to write
those things because I guess,
you know, to get the
emotional element on the page.
It's not just a question
of putting
on like a Whitney Houston song
and you'll be like all crying
and then writing because then
your writing isn't very good.
So it's really that
emotional part is hard for me.
>> Maria Russo: That's
interesting that you say
that because that's another
thing that kind of snuck
up about halfway
through the love story.
>> Marisha Pessl: Oh, okay.
>> Maria Russo: Which is always
is sort of buried in the --
you know that there
was this relationship
but we don't hear
anything about it.
And then halfway through
you sort of opened that up
and you write a very
beautiful love story.
>> Marisha Pessl: Oh
thank you, thank you.
>> Maria Russo: Teenage, you
know, teenager the tragedy
and wonder of teenage love.
>> Marisha Pessl: Right, right.
>> Maria Russo: That
feels like forever.
>> Marisha Pessl: Yeah, I
mean that is the hardest thing
for me personally to write
because it can be very
painstaking and you have
to get a lot of people
to read it and see
if something is reading.
Some of it feels very surgical
sometimes, I mean it's not just
as I was saying before just
like an outpouring of how I feel
as a writer it has
to be on the page.
And sometimes you can
feel emotional as a writer
and then it's not on the page.
So there's a huge difference
between what the
writer is feeling
and then what's on there yeah.
>> Maria Russo: Well we
are going to have some time
for questions, but I have one
more thing I really wanted
to ask about, which is so you've
been talking with teenagers
about this, but how
has their reaction been
and how has it been
to be in this world
of writing for teenagers?
>> Marisha Pessl: I
love it, I love it.
>> Maria Russo: Well can
you tell us a little bit
about what you've experienced?
>> Marisha Pessl: Yes, I
mean I will say even starting
out before the book even
came out entering this phase
and talking to teenagers.
I'm really struck by how
books become such a part
of their lives and how when
they love something it's really
something that is
very heartfelt.
In a way that with adults,
actually that's not true,
adults really love books too.
But there's just
something really pure
about that relationship
with books and adolescents.
And that very much reminds
me of my own experience,
so it's a return to that.
And also to see that the rumors
of books' deaths are
greatly exaggerated.
>> Maria Russo: Especially
if you look at the teenager.
>> Marisha Pessl: Yeah, I
know, I know, I remember.
>> Maria Russo: Children's
books.
>> Marisha Pessl: Exactly.
>> Maria Russo: Are just
this vibrant [inaudible] part
of our culture right now.
>> Marisha Pessl: Exactly and
it really gives me a great sense
of -- to be able to be a writer
is just such an amazing thing
and it's an act of bravery
and it's an act of giving
to people a story that
they hopefully enjoy.
It's a wonderful thing
to be able to do so.
>> Maria Russo: For the young,
for the next generation?
>> Marisha Pessl: Yes, yes.
>> Maria Russo: Have
you had a chance
to develop other favorite
current YA authors or?
>> Marisha Pessl: Yes, actually.
>> Maria Russo: Or past?
>> Marisha Pessl: Well so I
will say my favorite books
as a child were the Chronicles
of Narnia, like C. S. Lewis.
And now I'm reading
what's really popular
like [inaudible] Blood and Bone
and I'm so amazed by her talent.
And so I guess I'm starting out,
do you have any recommendations?
>> Maria Russo: Oh boy I
have way, way too many.
But should we give the audience
some time for questions soon
or how are we doing on time?
We have?
>> It's about 16, we have
about 14 minutes left.
>> Maria Russo: Okay let's
go over a few more questions,
a few more questions and
then we'll give you guys.
>> Marisha Pessl: Oh that's
right she has [inaudible].
>> Maria Russo: Okay great.
What else can I ask you about?
Okay there's one other theme
that I'm going to have to bring
up that is a big theme of yours
and you handle it really well.
But it's strong stuff
and this is death.
The way you write about death
to me is unlike any other
because you are so comfortable
with sort of the back and forth
and the boundary
between life and death.
And this is novel
that has several
because of the repeating day,
the characters die
and die and die.
>> Marisha Pessl: Right.
>> Maria Russo: There's many,
many death scenes for this book.
>> Marisha Pessl: Right.
>> Maria Russo: And almost all
of these characters get
to experience death.
>> Marisha Pessl: Right.
>> Maria Russo: And they
tell us what death is like.
>> Marisha Pessl: Right, right.
>> Maria Russo: So could you
talk a little bit about your,
how do you approach
writing about death
and did it feel different
doing that for teenagers?
>> Marisha Pessl:
That's interesting.
So how do I, well I think a lot
about death myself
I think simply
because obviously
is the great mystery
that we all wonder about.
But thinking of mortality
gives one a certain freedom
in your own action.
So I think I'm fairly
at ease with the idea
and it was exciting in this
particular book to answer
that question and to actually
like write a death scene
as I believe it to have
happened for certain people.
So that was actually really
exciting to be able to do.
And but no I wouldn't,
I certainly when I was writing
this book did not change how I
would write something for teens.
I didn't change anything
about my writing style,
in terms of writing
about death or life or anything.
I didn't want to, I guess
I didn't want to dumb
down certainly and I also
didn't want to shield my reader
from a certain reality.
I think that the young
adult audience can handle
really everything.
>> Maria Russo: Yes.
>> Marisha Pessl: In
terms of subject matter
and I think that they do.
And I think adolescent and young
readers can actually handle
subjects better than
adults sometimes.
>> Maria Russo: True, in fact.
>> Marisha Pessl:
Would have been mine.
Yeah.
>> Maria Russo: Teenagers
probably I would say think
about death a lot.
>> Marisha Pessl: Yes because
death touches their lives.
>> Maria Russo: In a sort
on theoretical way that you.
>> Marisha Pessl: Yes.
>> Maria Russo: Right.
And there's one scene where one
of your characters has
a death experience.
And I love this one so much
because you know she describes
what it's like and then she says
and finally it was just joy.
>> Marisha Pessl: Right.
>> Maria Russo: I thought
that was so comforting.
>> Marisha Pessl: Right, right.
Well and also, I
think I was inspired
by my own grandmother's
death especially
when I was writing Night
Film because I was raised
by my grandmother and
she passed away at 101
when I was writing that film.
And just seeing her in that
process really had a huge impact
on me and I felt
that there was joy
and that was really my
interpretation of being
with her in those times.
But there was a sadness
to let go
but then there was a
letting go and there was joy,
so I put that in the book.
>> Maria Russo: And as you
said, not the book is messaging
at all, but there is an implicit
message in that and I think
in the book, which is
that live your life
because we all know
death is right there.
Live your life with
purpose and meaning and joy.
>> Marisha Pessl: Yes and
I think about that too.
I think anytime I'm
afraid to try something,
especially in terms of writing
a book I just think we're all
headed to the same point
so why not you know really
climb the highest mountain
and see how far one can go so.
>> Maria Russo: You've
certainly done that.
>> Marisha Pessl: Well I don't
know about that, but thank you.
>> Maria Russo: Well we do have,
we are at our 10-minute mark,
so do we have some
questions for Marisha?
>> Do you want me to
go to the microphone
or I can use my teacher voice?
>> Maria Russo: The
teacher voice sounds good.
>> Marisha Pessl: You
have a wonderful voice
so we can hear you.
>> Thank you.
Okay, so first of all I
absolutely loved your two
first books.
>> Marisha Pessl: Oh
thank you so much.
>> It's very clear how
researched they were,
it was just incredibly, it
was incredibly [inaudible].
But you said first and foremost
if you are a reader or a writer
and you had mentioned that
Agatha Christie was one
of your favorite authors.
>> Marisha Pessl: Yes.
>> And I was curious what
other writers have influenced
your writing.
>> Marisha Pessl: Certainly.
I mean when I was a teenager
and really even now I read
everything I can get my
hands on.
So I was an English
literature major in college,
so I mean obviously the
greats like Charles Dickens.
I went through a little
obsession with Nabokov
at the time that I was
writing Special Topics.
So I would say Charles
Dickens primarily
because of just the sheer
boisterous nature of his novels.
And just how much one can
do within a story in terms
of the corporeality
of the characters
or addressing social issues.
And this big boisterous
tapestry to create,
I mean I always loved that idea.
More contemporary at the
time I loved Jonathan Franzen
and Jeffrey Eugenides
and American literary fiction
maybe 10 years ago I was really
obsessed with.
But now I'm going back
to the classics too
and it's always good to just
read a wide range, the high,
the low, the genre
of the literary.
>> Maria Russo: You were
saying the Secret Garden.
>> Marisha Pessl: Oh
yes, the Secret Garden.
I went Peter Pan and
now I have children
so now I'm revisiting
those children's classics.
>> Maria Russo: Oh, great.
>> Marisha Pessl: That
are just [inaudible].
The Little Princess, I mean all
of these like amazing books.
And some of them are and
actually Little Women too.
>> Maria Russo: Yes,
I just started watching
the PBS Little Women,
you have to watch that.
>> Marisha Pessl: I
have to watch that.
>> Maria Russo: It's very good.
Any other questions for --
oh, the light is so bright.
>> Marisha Pessl: Okay, hi.
>> So how challenging was
it having a plot where like
of course emotionally it would
matter the next day what they
had done, but physically like
it didn't matter what they did,
like you have so much room to
do anything you want there.
So how did you do
that in your book?
>> Marisha Pessl: You mean in
terms of having so much choice
because of the infinity
nature f the time?
>> Yeah.
>> Marisha Pessl: That's
such a good question.
So I had to limit myself
and I allowed the characters
to tell me their limits
because I was bound
by the nature of
these characters.
And so characters kept
me to a grounded place
as to what they were
going to do.
Beatrice was going to actually
try to get everyone to vote,
she was the responsible one.
She was the one who
really wanted to try this.
I won't go into all
of them, I don't want
to give away too much.
But I was bound by character.
And I have found no matter what
character is what you always
return to as a writer.
Whether you're going, you're
writing a huge sprawling epic
or a tiny little thing,
your characters are bound
by their sheer nature of
mortality, their circumstance.
It's really all about character
and that's the wonderful thing.
And that really keeps
you as a writer grounded
because you're writing
about people.
That's why I don't think I've
ever, I won't limit myself,
but to write about
aliens or something,
then there would be no limits
and it would truly be scary.
But people I can handle,
people have a corporality,
they have something
I can handle.
So that's how I dealt
with that infinity.
>> Okay, thank you.
>> Marisha Pessl:
You're welcome.
>> Maria Russo: Great.
Anyone else want to
step up to that mic?
>> I've got a question,
I've actually got a
couple of confessions.
>> Maria Russo: Oh
here's one here.
>> A couple of confessions
and a question.
My first confession is I
haven't yet read the new book,
so I don't know if my
question will apply to that.
>> Marisha Pessl: Okay.
>> To the book.
But my other confession is that
it's a little bit disarming
because you have exactly
the same mannerisms
as an ex-girlfriend of mine and
she's also a writer so I'm kind
of like, I'm kind of
freaking out, I'm sorry.
But my question is, in the
first two books you do a lot of,
obviously Night Film is a lot
about movies and so do you,
like do you think about
movies in the same way
and do you enjoy movies
the same way that you said
like you're a reader first?
Is film a big influence
on your writing?
Do you have a favorite
genre of film?
Favorite directors?
Does that kind of you
know work into your books?
>> Marisha Pessl: Yes, so I --
well so, I grew up with a mom
who was obsessed with
classical cinema.
So when my friends were out like
at a normal movie theater my mom
and I would be watching
like Turner classic movies
and I would be watching like
Howard Hawks and Preston Sturges
and His Girl Friday and
obsessed with Cary Grant
and Jimmy Stewart,
Alfred Hitchcock.
So that was another way
for me to really get
through my adolescence
was you know loving these
like old movies where
people had shoulder pads
and cigarette holders and
James Cagney and all these
like crazy characters.
So certainly like, you know,
like all influences in childhood
like that will play out in
one's art in different ways.
Certainly with Night Film the
original, the originating idea
for that was really
Stanley Kubrick and reading
about the behind-the-scenes
behavior that he really exerted
on his surroundings,
all in the name of art.
And the sort of various
means of torture
that different actors would
sign up for simply to be
in a Kubrick film and I just
found that so interesting.
Why were people allowing
themselves to be treated
like this, was it for the
fame, was it to get outside
of their day-to-day existence,
which maybe was dreary
and they wanted to go
off to sort of adult camp
and have some sort
of experience?
So I really started reading
about these you know
usually male film directors
and how they were
allowed and able
to like create art,
an art that we love.
I mean I love Alfred Hitchcock
and then it subsequently come
out as to how he actually
treated people behind the set,
so behind-the-scenes.
So really, that was
my originating idea.
So certainly, my childhood
was all about books and movies
but you know books that's my
centerpiece, that's my love.
>> Maria Russo: Two minutes.
Can I ask who is your
favorite character in the book?
>> Marisha Pessl:
Oh in Neverworld?
>> Maria Russo: Yeah,
because I think [inaudible].
>> Marisha Pessl: Definitely
Martha, [inaudible].
No, no. But I love them all,
I mean even my characters
who are bad.
>> Maria Russo: Yes,
all lovable,
they're all really lovable.
I'm not, I can't see with
the lights, anyone else?
Who here we are.
>> Marisha Pessl: Yes.
>> Can you step to
the microphone?
>> An adult film.
>> Marisha Pessl:
Oh say that again?
>> Could the new book have
been an adult film [inaudible]?
>> Maria Russo: He's saying
could the new book have been an
adult novel?
>> Marisha Pessl: No, I think,
well actually adults
who've read it have said
that it's not necessarily YA
and we were actually talking
about this, like what makes
something young adult.
I always conceived it as young
adult simply because the age
of the main characters.
And when I started working
with my young adult editor she
really said because of the age
of the characters it
makes it young adult.
But then Maria said.
>> Maria Russo: One rule of
thumb that some people use is
that if it's just
about teenagers,
but it's for grown-ups there
will be a sense of looking back
on what happened from
the grown-up perspective.
And there will sort
of signposts showing
that these characters
went on to adult lives
that is sort of the present.
Whereas in a YA book, you know
these characters really are
in the perspective of teenagers
you don't know what your
future's going to hold, you
don't know if you're going
to even survive into adulthood.
>> Marisha Pessl: Right, right.
>> Maria Russo: So
I think this does,
in some ways it's
classic YA in that sense
that it's not retrospective.
But you know as everyone here
probably knows YA is a new
category, it didn't exist when
you know Catcher and the Rye
and the Outsiders you know
these were just books.
And it's sort of a new
phenomenon to call,
to rope these off
and call then YAs.
So everybody should read
YA, what's called YA.
And in fact people say,
the publishing industry
will tell you 50%
of YA readers are
actually grown-ups.
>> Marisha Pessl:
Exactly, that's right.
>> Maria Russo: So I'm
sure lots of you here.
>> Marisha Pessl:
I think it started
with the Harry Potter
phenomenon.
>> Maria Russo: Right, exactly.
>> Marisha Pessl:
Everyone wants to go back
and read these stories
that they get lost in.
>> Maria Russo: Okay
we're going to wrap it up,
anyone want to sneak in a list
speed dating kind of question?
>> Marisha Pessl: Yes.
>> You said you were working
on your third novel for adults
when you got the idea
for Neverworld Wake
and I absolutely
love Night Film.
>> Marisha Pessl: Oh, thank you.
>> Do you know when your next
book for adults might come out?
>> Marisha Pessl:
It will be shortly.
I'm finishing it up and that's
about all I can tell
you but it's coming.
>> Maria Russo: Is it the one
that you discarded
the earlier idea?
>> Marisha Pessl: Oh no, no,
no that was another
young adult idea.
So no, I did not discard
this idea, definitely not.
So it's coming your
way but stay tuned
for more, I'm very excited.
>> Maria Russo: Did we get
everybody who wanted to,
we have probably to
sneak in one more.
>> Marisha Pessl:
Any other questions?
>> Maria Russo: Oh here we are.
>> Marisha Pessl: Yes, hi.
>> Maria Russo: Do you have
a question in the pink?
>> Marisha Pessl: Hi.
>> Are you going to make
another [inaudible]?
>> Marisha Pessl: Yes.
Yes, I definitely am.
So my plan is to switch, so I'm
going to write my next adult
and then I'm already working
on a new young adult,
so definitely.
>> Maria Russo: So you're
going to go back and forth?
>> Marisha Pessl: I think I'm
going to go back and forth.
>> Maria Russo: That is good
news for everyone in this room.
>> Marisha Pessl: Why leave
when it's so nice here,
I'm not going to leave.
So yes, I'm definitely writing
another young adult book
and more news on that soon.
>> Maria Russo: Well
fantastical.
Well Marisha Pessl,
thank you so much.
>> Marisha Pessl: Thank
you Maria so much for.
>> Maria Russo: It
was such an honor.
>> Marisha Pessl: Wonderful.